- Hi, I'm Megan from Khan Academy,
and in this video,
we'll browse through
Khan Academy together.
We'll start by logging into the platform,
and then go through
some of the key navigation
features together.
To get started,
go to khanacademy.org and click teachers
in the center of the screen.
If you have an existing Khan
Academy account, select login.
If you need to create
a Khan Academy account,
there are four registration options.
Using Gmail, Clever,
Facebook or another email account.
Now you're ready to get started.
Once you've set up your account,
you'll start on the teacher dashboard.
We are now viewing the teacher dashboard,
which is the homepage for teachers.
If you are seeing a different homepage
than the teacher dashboard,
you can adjust your homepage
to the teacher dashboard in settings.
Don't worry, we'll get to that soon.
There are a few important
items on this page.
The courses button,
which shows Khan Academy's content
organized by subject and course.
The search bar,
which you can use to find content quickly
by name or standard.
The Khan Academy logo,
it will always take you
to your chosen homepage,
and the navigation button,
which allows you to access
several other pages.
The navigation button,
which appears as your username,
can take you to a few essential locations,
including the learner homepage,
teacher dashboard, parent
dashboard and settings.
If you want to edit
your basic information,
you can do this from the settings page
from the dropdown of
the navigation button.
From the settings page,
you can edit basic account information
like username and primary language.
Reset your password,
know which email account
is linked to Khan Academy,
select your homepage,
and much more.
It is important to check if the
teacher function is selected
because only then will you have access
to the teacher dashboard.
We're selecting the teacher dashboard
from the dropdown menu.
If you'd like to learn more
about the learner homepage,
check out our video on
the student experience.
From the teacher dashboard,
you will find three very important tabs.
The class tab shows all
of your active classes.
If you select a class,
you'll be able to view the
roster, student activity,
mastery progress,
and assignments for that class.
We will discuss reports in
more detail in a later lesson.
If we return to the main teacher dashboard
by selecting the Khan Academy
logo at the top of the page,
the second tab you will
see is the students tab
on which you can view the
complete list of students
who are connected to your teacher account.
This list contains all of the students
currently associated with
your teacher account,
regardless of their assigned class.
Finally, from the main teacher dashboard,
you can access the resources tab,
which brings you to teacher
facing materials on Khan Academy
and also has a shortcut
to Khan for Educators.
We recognize that along
with your students,
many teachers want to
connect their own children
to their Khan Academy account.
From the navigation button,
you can access the parent dashboard
where parents can add their children
and create accounts for them,
in addition to monitoring the
progress they are achieving
with courses on the platform.
One last and important thing to point out,
where to find additional
help if you need it.
By clicking help from the
navigation button dropdown menu,
you have access to a page
full or resources about Khan Academy.
Community advice, and you
can even file a request
for help from our support team
to resolve any technical
issues that arise.
We hope this video helps you
find your way around Khan Academy.